What's up? Are you a Muslim?
>> Yes, I'm a new Muslim.
>> You're a new Muslim. How new?
>> Yeah, just converted
because Yeah, because I I figured out
Jesus is not God.
>> Okay. So, you uh converted like when?
Like yesterday? Two weeks ago?
>> Week ago. Week ago.
>> A week ago. Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> So, you so you embraced Islam?
>> Yeah. I just think that Jesus is not
God. I feel like
>> uh it's like more of like a
I would probably say like I would
probably say like I don't want to go to
hell. So I mean I just don't want to
believe that Jits is God.
>> Got you. So you're going to you chose
Islam that's going to that guaranteed
you hell anyway?
>> Um
[snorts] what do you mean?
>> Oh they they didn't they didn't tell
you?
>> No.
[sighs and gasps]
Did you look into Islam before joining
this Antichrist religion?
>> No, not really. I mean, I just looked at
Christ being God and
>> and that was it.
>> Yeah.
>> So, you looked at Christ being God, was
convinced that Christ isn't God, and
joined a religion that you don't know.
>> I mean, I thought I don't I mean, I
thought I don't know. I mean, it's okay.
Let me show you, bro. I'll teach you. So
this why I'm here so that you can make a
informed decision now. Okay. So I'm
going show you the religion that you
just joined.
You left Christ who you don't know and
was deceived about and joined a religion
that is full of delusion and falsehood
and guarantees you hell.
>> How do you How do you know it's like
illusion and falsehood?
>> I'm about to show you. I'm about to show
you that this is delusion and falsehood
right here. Okay. So this is uh let me
see if I can do
okay. This is how I have to do it. Okay.
Let me do it like this.
Me share this instead. Oh, I can't.
Okay.
All right. Sorry for my camera delay,
but this is the only way I can show you
the screen and show you the verses. All
right. You can see the screen. Yeah.
>> All right. So, this is chapter 19 of the
Quran. I'm going to read verses 68 to
72. All right.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. So, it says, "Now by thy Lord we
shall surely muster them and the Satans,
the Shayans. Then we shall parade them
about Gehenna hobbling on their knees.
Gehenna is hell." Okay.
Then we shall pluck forth from every
party whichever of them was the most
hardened in disdain of the all merciful.
Then we shall know very well the most
deserving to burn there. Right? So then
so Allah is going to know who's
deserving to burn there in hell. And now
watch what he says about all of you
guys, the Muslims, the believers. Not
one of you there is, but he shall go
down to it.
That for your Lord is a thing decreed
determined.
So Allah has decreed and determined that
there isn't going to be one of you, not
one of you is going to escape going down
to hell. Every single one of you
Muslims, even Muslims are going to go
down to hell. And then watch what Allah
is going to do. Then we shall deliver
those that were god-fearing
and the evildoers we shall leave there
hobbling on their knees. So even the
god-fearing Muslims will go to hell. The
upright
do goodter Muslims, they're going to go
to hell, but then Allah is going to
deliver them from hell after a while,
but leave the evildoers there.
And this is the religion you want to be
a part of something that where God
decrees that you have you're going to
hell regardless.
>> Okay. Well, just just prove to me that
Jesus Jesus claimed to be that Jesus is
God then.
>> Well, I could do that in a second. I
want to know if if this is a religion
that you want to follow that where God
decrees you to go to hell no matter what
you do.
>> I don't I mean, I'm not a professional.
I don't I'm pretty sure somebody has a
argument for that.
>> No, they don't. They they have lies for
it. But this is this is what the verse
says, right? Like you don't have to be a
scholar or you know nothing like that.
We we're we're thinking human beings. We
have reading comprehension. We can read
what's in front of us. So we can clearly
see from the text that Allah is going to
send everyone to hell, even the Muslims.
Is that a reliable hadith?
>> It's not a hadith. It's a Quran. Well,
yeah, it is a It is the most It's the
best Hadith according to the Quran. The
Quran is the best Hadith, it says.
>> So,
>> Oh, this
um
>> Yeah, this is a Quran verse, brother.
I'm not reading.
>> That's in the
>> This is chapter 19 of the Quran.
>> Oh. Oh, I thought that was a hadith.
>> No.
>> Well, I'm pretty I mean there there's
billions of Muslims. I'm pretty sure
like they interpret it, but I understand
what you mean. I'm not trying to like,
you know, you know, be like that.
>> Good. I hope not. Yeah. Let's be honest
with the text. So, are you are you okay
with joining a religion that where Allah
decrees and determines for you to go to
hell, even being a Muslim, he guarantees
you hell? Is this the religion you want
to be a part of?
>> No. No. I mean based on that verse and
based on what I know now I would say no.
>> Okay. So this is the rel this is the
religion you joined bro matter of fact
let me show you something else. Now I'm
going to show you a hadith and then I
and then I'll show you that Jesus is
God. I'm going to show you the religion
that you joined. Okay
>> that's what I do. I teach the I teach
you the people the religion that they
joined so that they can be informed
about what they've done. All right. This
is watch what uh watch what watch what
Muhammad teaches in the authentic
hadith. Everything I show you is going
to be authentic. Nothing I show you is
going to be weak or whatever. All right.
>> Okay.
>> All right.
This is sahi. Sahi means authentic. Sahi
Muslim 2748B.
You can see it.
>> Mhm. Yeah.
>> Watch what it says.
>> Little bit blurry, but
>> it's a little blurry. Yeah, but I mean I
hear what it say.
>> It says Abu Ayatsar
reported that Allah's messenger said so
Muhammad taught it said if you were not
to commit sin
Allah would have swept you out of
existence and would have replaced you by
another people who have committed sin
and then asked forgiveness from Allah
and he would have granted them pardon.
So this this hadith says and it's
authentic nobody can come against it.
This hadith says that if you don't
commit sin Allah is going to destroy you
if you don't sin
and then replace you with people who
will sin and then ask him for
forgiveness so he can forgive them.
>> I mean we're bound to sin.
>> Say that again.
>> We're we're bound to sin.
>> We are we're bound to sin. But does God
want us to sin?
>> No.
>> No. But according to this, the God of
Islam wants us to sin. If we don't sin,
then he's going to destroy us.
>> I mean, it it depends on how you
interpret that verse.
>> No, there's there's there's no
interpreting. Let me read it again. If
you were not to commit sin,
Allah would have swept you out of
existence.
You see that?
>> Yeah.
>> So, there's there's no way else to
interpret that. It just it says exactly
what it says. If you don't commit sin,
Allah will destroy you. He won't even
get you. Let because if you go to hell
and heaven, you still exist. This say he
will he will sweep you out of existence.
He'll completely destroy you.
And then watch what he'll do. And he'll
replace you would have replaced you by
another people who would have committed
sin.
So he wants you to sin rather than not
sin. Right? according to this idea.
>> According yes, I I grant you that. Yeah.
Based on my knowledge right now.
>> Now, let me ask you this. Who is the
entity that actually wants us to sin?
That that wants us to commit crimes,
that wants us to do evil. What Who is
that entity that wants us to sin?
>> Uh the evil one.
>> And who is that?
>> Satan.
>> Satan. Bro,
so you joined a religion that guarantees
you hell and you joined a religion where
their god is likened to Satan. Has the
same desires that Satan has in that he
wants you to sin. He wants you to commit
evil. Allah is the evil one.
This is what you joined. How how did the
um da people respond to what you just
said?
>> Similar to actually how you responded
the first time, how we are we're we're
we're bound to sin, right? We
everybody's going to sin. We can't help
it and Allah knows that. And so what
this is what this hadith communicates is
that it shows that we you know we we
we're going to sin and uh and Allah is
forgiving when we do. if we seek
forgiveness, he's he's ready to forgive
us. That that's their response, but it
doesn't solve the problem. We hear them.
We we know that we're bound to sin.
That's not what this hadith says. This
hadith says if you don't sin,
if you don't sin, Allah is going to
destroy you and replace you with
sinners. So according to the hadith,
it's very clear no matter how you how
you try to explain it or break it down.
According to the hadith, it's explicit
that Allah would rather have you sin and
need his forgiveness than not sin and
follow him perfectly. He would rather
you sin and and do evil.
In the Bible, God says, "Be perfect as
your father in heaven is perfect."
That's what the Bible says.
>> The Bible says that the righteous and
the ones who obey God's commands and
adhere to his words, they will be
rewarded.
That the righteous will inherit the
earth. The servants of God, the
righteous servants of God will inherit
the earth. Right? But the the hadith
says if you're righteous, he'll destroy
you if you're completely righteous. If
you obey Allah perfectly without fail,
you do everything you're supposed to do
without fail, he's going to destroy you
and replace you with sinners. People who
would fail.
>> Okay. I I I grant you that. Yeah, I
grant you that.
>> This is This is a false This is why I
said this is a religion full of delusion
and falsehood, bro. It it it paints God
this this is a false This is why I say
this is a false god. paints him as a as
an evil um as an evil one who sends
everyone to hell in the first place
anyway, no matter what you do. And and
demands that we sin rather than live
holy and not sin.
This is not this is not from God very
clearly.
>> Okay. Well, okay. I agree. Okay. But but
the whole reason why I did that is
because I just I was just convinced that
you know Christ is not God. And you know
it it it was um
uh [snorts] it was like a emotional
emotion um decision also a um factual
decision.
>> Mhm.
>> I didn't want to go to uh hell from my
decision. And also, I just believe that
the gospel did not teach that he was
God, nor the Trinity, and it just seemed
like it was just deception.
>> Okay.
>> All right. So, let's talk about this
then.
And and even if I'm sorry, even if um I
were to be convinced that Islam is
false, I would still just be either like
a Jehovah's Witness or like a like a
like a um something like a Unitarian or
something like that.
>> Okay.
Okay.
So let's go to the Bible then. [snorts]
Let me actually make this bigger [sighs]
so we can see the verses.
>> Bible.
>> All right. Can you see the verses now?
Is it better?
>> Uh yeah, I can see.
>> All right. So this is Titus chapter 2
verse 13.
It says,
"Waiting for our blessed hope, the
appearing of the glory of our great God
and Savior Jesus Christ."
>> Great. So,
>> great. Great God and Savior Jesus
Christ.
>> So, how I interpret it, like I know like
my interpretation is just like who cares
about this guy interpretation, you know?
Yes. But
>> um how I look at it is like um it's
talking about it's it's not talking
about um Jesus and God like the same
thing. It's talking about God and uh
savior Jesus Christ.
>> Who's the one that's coming?
>> Is the father coming or is Jesus coming?
>> Christ,
>> right? So the appearance is of Christ,
not the father.
So notice what it calls Christ. It calls
him our great God and Savior.
>> Well, okay. Well, can we go to like a
more reliable?
>> What do you mean more? What do you mean
more reliable? This is the Bible.
>> I mean,
like like more reliable as in like the
>> Is this not Is this not clear that it's
calling Jesus our great God and Savior?
Well, what Titus I mean Titus is I mean
I I if I say anything it would be like a
stretch and you know I mean
>> I just just based on the brother just
based on based on the text just be
honest with the text
>> does the text identify Christ as our
great God and Savior.
>> Yeah. Uh yeah
>> okay simple right it's not it's not
hard. We just got to be honest with the
text. That's all. So,
>> I'm trying to be honest, but
>> Yep. That's good. Yep. Let's stay
honest. So, yes. So, here's one of them.
Christ is our great God and Savior.
Let's do another one. Here's Romans 9:5.
To them belong the patriarchs, talking
about the Israelites. To them belong the
patriarchs,
and from their race according to the
flesh is the Christ, who is God overall.
Blessed forever. Amen.
It's Romans chapter 9 verse 5.
>> Paul
Yep. Paul is right.
>> Explain why um um um what's the name?
Muslims call him a false prophet.
>> I I don't It's because they need
somebody to point at for for the reason
why Muhammad contradicts Jesus and
everybody else. So they try to point at
Paul say, "Oh yeah, Paul corrupted
everything." So it's silly when even in
their own sources, Paul is a messenger
of Jesus.
>> Yeah.
>> So they have no grounds to go against
Paul.
>> So
okay, I I grant you that cuz I mean
[clears throat] I feel like if I say
anything else, it'll be like a stretch.
>> Yeah. Let's just let's just be honest
with the text. So we got another one,
right, that identifies Christ as God,
right?
>> Yeah. Okay. But that's that's that's
Paul. Well, I mean,
>> so what you said nowhere in the Bible,
you said the Bible doesn't teach that
Jesus is God.
>> Okay. Yeah.
>> Okay. Let me show you another one. Now,
this ain't Paul. This is Jesus himself.
Revelation 22:12-13.
Behold, I am coming soon, bringing my
recompense with me to repay each one for
what he has done.
I am the alpha and the omega, the first
and the last, the beginning and the end.
So Jesus is very clearly claiming to be
God, right? By claiming to be the first
and the last, beginning and the end,
alpha and omega. He's clearly claiming
to be God, right?
>> Um I mean, yeah. I mean I mean what what
what does that necessarily mean?
>> The alpha and omega, the first and the
last, the beginning and the end. It
means that he is the eternal one. He's
infinite. He's always been. He's the
beginning and he's the end. He's the
first and the last, the alpha and the
omega. That means he is eternal and has
always been the source of all things.
Okay. This is also what God calls
himself in the Old Testament. Hold on,
let me get
>> You're familiar with that, right?
>> Um
Isaiah.
>> Yeah, exactly.
Isaiah
>> No, not Isaiah 50 something. No, it's
>> it's in the 40s.
>> Yeah, 40 43.
>> No,
um I'm actually having a brain fart now
that you're saying all that. I think
it's is it 428? Let's see.
>> Here we go.
Here we go.
Here it is. Isaiah 48:12,
"Listen to me, oh Jacob and Israel, whom
I called. I am he. I am the first and I
am the last."
All right? And that's exactly what Jesus
says about himself. I am the first and
the last, the beginning and the end, the
alpha and the omega. Jesus is claiming
to be God, right?
>> Yeah. In re revel Yes. in revelation.
But that that's I can't that's that's a
revelation that the father gave the son
>> brother it's a revelation that he gave
the son to give to his servant. That's
what it says. This is the revelation of
Jesus which God gave him to give to his
servant John. Meaning he has permission
to reveal this to him. Not that Jesus
didn't know this about himself already.
>> Okay. [clears throat]
>> Okay. So we we we very clearly and this
is just a few verses, but we very
clearly have the Bible teaching that
Jesus is God, right?
>> Yeah.
>> So if anybody is telling you that the
Bible teaches that Jesus isn't God,
they're a liar and they're being
dishonest or they simply are very
ignorant, right, and following lies.
>> Yeah. But what what about the father
being like he didn't like the father um
um is greater than I and um
>> and yeah Jesus humbled himself. He
humbled himself and took on the form of
a servant. That's why he could say that
the father is greater than he is because
he humbles himself to the father.
Similar similar to how you humble
yourself to your boss, right? But that
doesn't mean that doesn't mean that you
that your bosses or that you're not
human anymore since you
>> like like the president.
>> Exactly.
>> Yeah. Like greater role. So So the
father's greater greater in role or is
he
>> Yeah. Yeah. Because the son takes a
humble role to the father. He takes a
servant role to the father.
>> 68.
And I have a question about Philippians
2:62. Cuz I got I got confused like the
other day on it. It says,
so talking about Christ, have this mind
in you which was also in Christ Jesus,
who though he was in the form of God,
did not count equality with God a thing
to be grasped, something he had to hold
onto, but emptied himself by taking the
form of a servant, being born in the
likeness of men, and being found in
human form, he humbled himself by
becoming obedient to the point of death,
even death on a cross.
Well,
um then this is my question I had like
the other day like you see how it says
like um can you go up a little bit? I'm
sorry.
Um you see where it says did not count
equality with God thing to be grasp.
Does that mean like he didn't like what
does that mean? It means that he decided
to humble himself and not hold on to his
status with the father. That's why it
says like in the uh in the King James
version actually gets it it communicates
this very well. It says that he did not
count equality with God a thing to be
grasped but made himself of no
reputation. That's what it says in the
King James version. So it communicate it
communicates this very well that Christ
although having that status and that
glory with the father decided to make
himself of no reputation humbled himself
made himself nothing right um and that's
what this is communicating here being
found
uh took on the form of a servant being
born in the likeness of men and being
found in human form he humbled himself
by becoming obedient
Right? So even though he is equal with
the father and you know has shares that
glory with the father that's not
something he held on to. He he set that
aside to come and do what he had to do.
>> Okay.
>> Make sense?
>> Yeah.
>> So the Bible clearly teaches that Jesus
is both God and man simultaneously. This
is why you'll see Jesus, you know,
saying the father is greater than I or I
come to do my father's will, right? Uh
the I came to do the will of him who
sent me, not my own and yada yada yada.
Jesus is not a rogue ninja that is
coming out doing his own thing.
Everything he does is in tandem with the
father and vice versa. The father does
nothing without the son either. They are
inseparable. They always work together.
They have different operations in these
actions, right? They have their own
role. However, they never work apart
from each other. They are inseparable.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> So, are you convinced now that the Bible
teaches the deity of Christ? [snorts]
>> Uh, I mean, I would say yeah, but I I
would have to listen to um like my my
other uh people.
>> Who's your other people?
>> You know, like my you know, Unarian
friends and my Muslim friends. Why would
you listen to them who go against Jesus?
No,
>> I'm just saying like like just listen to
their argument.
>> Yeah. Why Why would you Why would you go
with them who's lying on Jesus and
giving you a false Jesus? Why? First,
why would you even go to a Muslim when
we just demonstrated is Islam is false
and has a false god, a satanic god? Why
would you even Why would you go to a
Muslim?
>> Okay. Okay. my unarian friends. Like,
>> why would you go to a unarian who's
denying what the scripture says about
Jesus?
>> Just to like hear their argument. Like,
you know, you know how you just like
weigh an argument?
>> Yeah, I got you.
>> It's not, you know.
>> All right, bro. Well, are you still a
Muslim?
>> I would say no. Not currently.
>> Amen. Keep reading the Bible, man. Keep
listening to these streams. I pray that
God guides you to his truth and
ultimately you can see who Christ really
is and that you're able to discern that
the Holy Spirit gives you discernment to
be able to flesh out the lies from his
word. Remember, you saw today clear
scripture that Jesus is God. If anybody
tells you otherwise, you know that that
person's a liar. Okay? So, you're
welcome to come back anytime, man. Keep
joining. Keep watching. I appreciate the
good conversation, brother. Thank you
for your honesty, man. Thank you for
being honest. I appreciate that. No
problem.
>> For sure. God bless you, bro.
>> Bless, bro.
>> All right.
>> Yeah. Everybody pray for that man. Pray
for that young pray for that young
brother right there. Man was duped into
Islam. Just left Islam after seeing
Islam as a falsehood, a lie from Satan.
The God is that Allah is a false god and
a satanic entity.
And now he's just stuck in the middle of
a of of knowing who Jesus truly is. So,
Holy Spirit, please reveal yourself to
him, give him the truth, and protect him
from the liars that will ensnare him and
try to trap him and lie about who Jesus
is to give him a false gospel.
Open his heart, Lord. Reveal yourself to
him. In Jesus name we pray.